[Music]
hi everybody welcome to et live I am
Lauren Zima and I'm Kristen Gill and I'm
Katie Krauss and we are going to be
breaking down the biggest fashion
moments from Sunday night's Emmy Award
of course you want to know what you guys
think as well because there were so many
looks and we are so excited to talk
about them so leave your comments leave
your questions on e t--'s Facebook page
right now we'll get them here on our
phones and make sure to comment about
any of the hairstyles and makeup because
we've got all of those tips and tricks
and also just any information the Queen
has been in touch with should we get
started with Nicole Kidman yes a lady
elegant in red it is so hard you guys to
find a red dress that looks good on a
red carpet
she went with Calvin Klein by
appointment and I want to just bring up
the fact that she's wearing two million
dollars worth of Harry Winston jewels
this look was I mean she radiated the
red carpet I feel like it was her night
she won for big little lies Best Actress
and the show won as well yes Oh what did
you guys think of it I couldn't agree
more I felt like Nicole owned the night
in so many ways you see her posing with
Keith Urban there I mean from start to
finish she killed it on the red carpet
her speeches were amazing and you can
check out her speeches over at ICI
online.com and then what I loved about
her look is I couldn't stop looking at
it to decipher all of the details about
it you know it was like that beautiful
sparkly piece was it part of the dress
was it necklace also her shoes they're
her shoes were like mismatched a little
bit which was it was intentional that
way yes that was the thing it was she
was both classic and super intriguing
like you just couldn't figure it out and
that bold red lip I talked to Kylie
Heath actually her hairstylist and she
said they just wanted to go with a
timeless look and that the dress
actually reminded her of a Barbie doll
and she just went with this soft braid
and it just kind of kept it modern by
clipping it up and just having those
little tresses falling down on her
shoulders to really showcase that dress
you know what else I loved about the
dress is the length it wasn't too long
it wasn't too short so when she hit up
all those after parties she could date
she wasn't gonna be falling all over it
it was like she could get her her moves
on exactly and you know I talked to the
big little lies gals on the red carpet
of course they all stopped at ETS
platform and zoe kravitz was saying
she's like that's the thing is we all
are so close from working on this show
that no matter what happens tonight we
just want to celebrate after together
they want to have some drinks they want
to dance she said she they were all
texting before so yeah and also you know
I think when you're a celebrity and
you're as big as Nicole Kidman a movie
and TV star she knows she's probably
have to go to the Oscars so she has to
differentiate a little bit you know how
is the Emmys maybe not quite as
black-tie as the Oscars and I think the
length of the dress helped with that a
little bit I completely agree should we
move on to miss Arielle or winter yes
now Arielle not so seasoned on the red
carpet isn't a cold Kidman you know
she's a younger lady so her look was was
a little bit more controversial maybe
not as beloved but what did you guys
think so she's wearing Sioux hair Murad
I want to say first of all and I love
the top of the dress but then as you go
down and you see those two salutes it's
like whoa mama
to me if there was just one slit I would
have loved it but the two it's a little
bit much
yeah but the top again is is perfect
it's so shiny and beautiful and she
looks great there's her boyfriend right
there I think she is still you know she
is so figuring out her style and
figuring out her body and she what I
love about Arielle winter is she's so
open about that like she talks about
that in interviews on Instagram about
how look I'm owning Who I am figuring
out who I am making mistakes along the
way and ultimately at the end of the day
she's a beautiful girl and she looked
gorgeous but Kristin talked about the
hair I love her mink I know I loved her
makeup too Kip Zachary did her makeup
for the look and he said he saw the
beading and knew that he wanted to go
with that metallic eye and her hair
stylist was Charles do Jake and he knew
that that collar was so high she needed
something simple for her hair so we just
kind of put it back but still there was
something interesting and it was kind of
flowy and long and that was really the
background behind the hair and makeup
we're already getting lots of comments I
liked Ariel's look Mallory says Moulin
Rouge vibes I'm assuming that's for
nicole kidman
yeah and Cathy says Nicole always looks
I told you guys I had this little moment
I have to say it was so adorable on the
red carpet watching because Keith Urban
you know it wasn't his night he didn't
want to get into interviews with Nicole
he was letting the big little eyes gals
do interviews together but he's just
standing looking up at her on the
platform like in awe of her and then I
grabbed him as he walked by and I'm like
Keith how do you feel about tonight and
he goes I'm just extremely proud and she
looks beautiful as always like eat loves
her so much watching him give her speech
that was more exciting to me than
anything else was just like looking at
how much love he has for her right
watching him watch alright let's move on
to Reese Witherspoon another big little
eyes gout now this look was another one
where I feel like people were really
talking about it it was much more I
don't know if casual is the right word
but you know Nicole's in a gown and
Reese's in this kind of short blazer
look her legs look amazing I'm missing
my Stella McCartney it's just so casual
and I feel like Reese Witherspoon is
someone that you can always count on to
deliver on the red carpet and I get that
maybe she was going for that whole boss
lady vibe I mean she was up for
executive producer for big little lies
but this was a little bit too casual it
looks like she forgot her pants I know I
know she looked like a strong woman
definitely that bold red lip is
everything but I felt like the hair I
did I want to know I didn't get to speak
to any of her like stylists I know Petra
Flannery its styled her and I would love
to talk with her about what exactly went
on behind the scenes picking this outfit
I get it she is a very strong
independent woman she's executive
producer like you said but I just felt
like there was a little less feminine
Andy than we're used to seeing her like
in that beautiful yellow dress she wore
years back and she knows how to slay
that carpet this was just not yourself
in this vision that she went with to end
up wearing this what did you think I
felt like the look would have been
perfect at a different event maybe if it
was a preeminent yeah I mean there's so
many Emmys parties over the weekend I
could have seen her wearing that to the
television Academy party on Friday night
I just thought we needed a little bit
more from the Emmys but also at the end
of the day I mean if you just look at
the woman's face she's stunning and she
ageless like her skin looked amazing and
by the way you don't what they all
preach so much as hydration I heard
somebody ask Nicole Kidman what you have
to do for a red carpet let's just drink
water she said she splashes her face
cold water in the morning great another
blonde miss julianne hough katie i know
you love this look Tommy
guys this is Marchesa this is so
romantic which is so fitting because she
just got married a couple months ago
look at those 3d cherry blossoms just
draped over the dress down the back as
well then you have the sheer bodice -
it's like - line thing this was
perfection for me in Julianne Hough
Julianne Hough always slays it on the
red carpet and this is just the latest
example I can't say how expensive burns
actually I spoke with him and he was
telling me that she had faux freckles on
you can't really see on her face
freckles yeah yeah it was like very
angelic and I think that it just speaks
to how happy and just like I don't know
youthful Julianna's and she is very much
so and she has that little ribbon in the
back of her hair Rihanna did her her
hair that's her go-to girl at 9:01 salon
you know yeah just got Rihanna and
Spencer and she just has a beautiful
pouty pink lip and just was a very
youthful look you guys well the details
just blow my mind right to think that
someone thinks of faux freckles that's
why these people are in this upper
echelon of chilling it on the Emmys red
carpet because they have a creative team
that's thought about things to that
level yeah I also want to talk about her
brows I feel like her and Cara
Delevingne were the two women in
Hollywood who really brought back those
faking brows what is the secret can you
tell me people don't realize you have to
do kind of a mixture between a wax and
also like a powder okay so any eyeshadow
and it's a couple shades darker than
your hair is usually what you want to go
with and then you mix it with a lighter
to kind of let it match your natural
hair tones I guess so you don't to be
too bold bit soft and I felt like her
brows
had a little bit of a different shape
even than they usually do it's something
about her face looked a little bit
different I think maybe she did a
heavier brow okay very hard she's
harsher brow but I like it
yeah contrast with the kind of this
floor
real feminine dress really well more
comments coming in from you guys Susie
says Reese's outfit was more Golden
Globes not Emmys and Isabel says that
the coat dress should have been maybe
full length a lighter texture and pink
Isabelle has a whole plan I love it and
rosemary said sorry for Reece but not
this time Jenny says Nicole Kidman was
stunning and Kathy yeah loving the
florals on giuliana Shelly thinks she
looks too out of the best of the night
let's go on to Tandi newton she is
wearing Jason Wu it's this beautiful
except pink color and then you have all
the glitzy details as you go into the
skirt part of it the top bodice is I
mean it fits her perfectly it's it
accentuates how tiny she truly is her
arms look insane she's so fit but I just
love you see how slowly she was stepping
down that red carpet it's because she
knows that with each step its glittering
its glitz saying it it wasn't in LA yes
it was gorgeous and then I loved how
they kind of paired her skin with this
super glow to it it's I mean what do you
think they put on in terms of something
to give you that glow on the red carpet
it's as simple as baby oil sometimes you
may smell and her hair was pulled back
so it really showcased the dress and she
had a very light makeup
I think Kay Montano did her makeup she
does a makeup app and website with her
it's like her bestie so I think that she
looked flawless yeah she truly did that
the light makeup I think was the key for
that definitely a dress a dress oh yeah
yes yes we also had miss Mandy Moore and
how Kristin I know you love this look of
the night look at Mandy I mean people
are comparing her to an Oreo and I was
like no way
tulle is everything the black and white
and that pop of the pink lip and then
she had the hair a little bit over that
I because she did injure that I remember
oh yes she walked into a shower door
setting so her hair stylist just really
laid it on that you can't even tell and
she just has that engaged glow you know
she's just got engaged her man and I
just thought she was glowing from head
to toe so this gown is Caroline Herrera
and while I love the makeup I love that
pop of pink on her lips I don't love the
dress oh because I feel like if it was a
completely all black silhouette I would
have loved it I'm not liking the white
sandwiched in between the black or
threatened at the white did not go
another another layer the only thing
that I don't love I think this dress
turned into actually one of the most
controversial toxins of the night
because of what we're seeing right here
I mean I I think maybe more is more in
Carolina Herrera before and she looked
beautiful she always does I kind of
never forgot about the eye thing or
Instagram you guys it's pretty nice
sheet of black I choose asking
commenters for help on how to cover it
up um I think the thing is it's black
and white and at the end of the day you
can't really go wrong with black and
white definitely not on a worse dress
look by any means and you know what I
think she was dressing for a big moment
this is us we had the chance to break
the network drama curse last night and
she thought I want to be in a big dress
for this but it was definitely I talked
about without the Rita says for Mandy I
just wished that weight in the middle
was black and that she would have been
best dressed cuz I agree if it was all
black hands down best rest of the night
it was really pretty me Audrey Hepburn
right I slay that and Breakfast at
Tiffany's that's how it was yeah we also
had miss Jessica Biel and I gotta talk
about this one because I just loved her
look first of all I loved Jessica Biel
at the Emmys last night she was there
presenting so she was just having a
playful time but just killing it look at
those legs and that dress was so dynamic
between the sparkles and the sleeves and
her hair with the volume on it and then
kind of a lighter makeup I just loved it
Katie what can you tell us about the
dress so the dress is by Ralph and Russo
JLo and lots of stars just love Ralph
and Rizzo but I know that Jayla was like
the biggest so she did she radiated on
the red carpet she is shimmering like
look at that off the shoulder like
sleeve it's like draping them on her
back yeah and in the main oh um she's so
muscular look at her
happy that that slit is so high so that
you can actually see the definition on
her legs the only thing that I don't
love about this is the hair your dress
is so perfect that I wish that the hair
didn't have so much volume going on
because it almost distracts from the
dress but I loved it I loved it I loved
the volume too and I thought it added a
romanticism and I think what I love so
much about Jessica Biel like even
without fashion right now is that we're
seeing her kind of come out of who new
mom you know and get back into her
career like she has Silas and now she's
got a new show the center and you know
she hit the red carpet without Justin
last night he was over a track and Rio
then we interviewed her you can check
that interview out on ET tonight of
course and she was telling Nancy though
she's like I don't wake up looking like
this it takes work but I'm here and I'm
having fun she was having a drink alone
in the limo on the way there like
Jessica's being playful which I loved
you know she had that pompadour and it
was not my favorite when I see it I love
Jessica Biel but I dear Mariko I'm so
sorry her hairstylist but that was just
not my thing he said though that he was
inspired by 1960s high glamour for this
look and I totally see that once I read
that it was like okay I get it now but
still pompadour maybe just a little pony
would have been cool but it was the
perfect blend though of like sexy and
chic yeah I'm gonna give her that oh I
heard back I mean the open back on it
like you said she's body's amazing Jane
Fonda you guys the Queen good night the
woman is what you see 1779 she is
turning English amber and she looks this
good look at this I mean I literally
when the phone with my mom earlier and
my mom goes Jane found it looked so good
you know how old is she
cuz that's the thing she is the
definition of ageless and you think
she'd look good for any age and then you
find out she's 79 you think this Queen
killing it and I mean we were the only
ones fangirling out over her Jessica
Biel posted an Instagram with her she
was like meeting her feminist icon and
then yeah and then I think Sofia Vergara
instagrammed with her as well I mean did
you what do you think did you like the
Jane look or was it too youthful for her
you guys feel bad you know what when you
were 79 year
old and you were jane fonda you can do
no wrong no matter what you do the dress
is by brandon maxwell and when we spoke
to her on the red carpet she said that
those jewels she's wearing nearly two
million dollars worth of jewels were
flown in from Geneva that day and I love
the contrast of the emerald green with a
pink lake
nothing says a party like bright pink
and bright green together she was just
having fun you know I talked to her and
I'm like how do you attack the red
carpet she goes with a martini and you
guys won't believe who her look was
actually inspired by so when I talked to
her she told me what other celebrity was
her is her red carpet inspiration I
watched what Gwen Stefani does on a red
carpet and try to copy her and that's
the truth it doesn't come naturally to
me but she doesn't so great so I try to
do what she does so your Gwen Stefani
inspired to write and you can see it
with the P tail 100% 100% I feel like on
the voice Gwen wore almost that exact
hairstyle and so I completely see where
she got inspired by for that look yeah
her makeup artist David de Leon actually
wrote me and he said that he and the
hairstylist collaborated for about a
week coming up with this look and they
were actually inspired by Jean Shrimpton
from the 1960s as well as Gwen Stefani
and just came up with this mod matte lip
glowing cheeks topped you know just she
just looked for their working woman yes
and she had a graphic liner which is so
rare for a 79 year old to be wearing
like a graphic twing liner and she
killed it I also love the bell sleeves
yeah so in style so on trend right now
what I think was awesome too is I
actually almost think if someone younger
or a different person had worn that we
might have said it was like over the top
but you just learned everything about it
yeah so Sofia Vergara poster with her
what can you tell us about Sofia's looks
okay so she was wearing Mark Zunino
she loves Mark soon you know she's
worked with him a lot she says that he
knows how to dress a curvy woman this is
stunning the only problem that I have is
that she always goes for a dress like
that I know I think she's in a catch-22
because she has said she has such a
curvaceous body and so she really
had support on the red carpet and you
know she wants to make sure she looks
good so she does she goes for a very
similar silhouette every time that's her
son with her she told us actually that
Joe Manganiello her husband is shooting
a movie in New York right now so that's
why he could not be with her at the
Emmys that interview is also on ET
online what do you think what what about
her makeup what can you tell us you know
kelly kline did her hair actually and
pulled out those bangs and I had never
seen her really rock a bang before and I
felt like it kind of made it a little
less what's the word it was a little
more casual let's just put it that way
and I thought maybe a pulled back pony
but that she always does that you know
she pulls her hair back so the bangs
were different and I really appreciated
that and it's fall now so that berry lip
really just kind of brought the look
together well that's the thing you know
this is Modern Family I think this is
maybe their eighth year at the Emmys
yeah so when she's hitting that red
carpet every year and if she wants to
stick with that silhouette she's really
got to try to find ways to switch it up
in other ways more comments coming in
from you guys Sabrina
well that was Sabrina agreeing on the
white Bob Jessica Biel was Best Dressed
hands-down Kathy says Jessica's look was
gorgeous and Jennifer says my favorite
so far she looked gorgeous and then
Sabrina Levin genes ponytail she had so
Millie Bobbie Brown you guys a little
queen from stranger things what did you
guys think of this look she really
Uthoff eyed yeah a pretty elegant dress
so she looks like a chic ballerina this
is also Calvin Klein by appointment the
same designer as Nicole Kidman wore to
me if you look closely I don't know if
we can like zoom in but she's wearing a
bandanna oh look at that a bandanna tied
around the dress she is a 13 year old
fashionista yeah I mean who would think
to go with that kind of look for the
Emmys because you might think a bandana
is that gonna work is that gonna be
weird to me it works for you guys please
definitely yeah you got us talking you
know but I think her dewy skin is very
youthful or her makeup artist didn't go
with anything too crazy just did like a
lip balm on the lips and then her hair
style is just pulled her hair back in
that beautiful little bun and it let the
dress speak for itself
really had a moment yeah that's the
thing is you have to think about how
they have to balance age
you know what the event is I mean she's
a very young teenager so I kind of loved
it was like bandana belt you know she
gave it a little a little edge love her
okay let's dive into someone we were all
so obsessed with zoe kravitz and guys
from big little lies I mean her face is
stunning and then this dress
unbelievable Katie tell us about it so
this is Dior Haute Couture that's how
you say it in the high fashion world
it's almost like a mood ring like no
matter what way she's looking you're
gonna have a different color kind of
popping in the backing of those blues
and those greens in the front you have
the yellows and the pinks and the
oranges and it looks like a rainbow but
this is the perfect dress for her
because it's so chic but it has that
element of edginess which is how I would
describe her yeah totally I talked her
about her look here's what she had to
say about how she picked the dress and
combined it with those jewels you are so
bold with your fashion choices which we
love but how did you pick this dress was
it the first the 10th you tried on it
was the second I tried on and I mean it
was just so special I had never seen me
anything quite like it
so and when do you get to wear something
like this you know how do you come up
with the idea to pair it with Tiffany
jewelry it's like edgy but classic it's
so um I think that's kind of exactly
what it is the dress is really edgy and
we just wanted something really kind of
simple to kind of elevate the dress and
they worked really well together okay
feathered ombre do we like it or do we
not I loved it on her I mean she's got
that cute little haircut in that
stunning face it's like she almost has
to dress a little bit differently
because her beauty is so unique and she
needs to raise the bar with her clothes
for herself definitely I love how you
asked her how she decided to pair the
Tiffany jewels with that I mean right I
personally I don't even I would not feel
confident enough in myself to wear this
look and she just owns it she is like oh
like a Mia Farrow or something oh that's
just gorgeous
high-fashion boho yeah Nikki Nelms did
her hair and I really felt like it the
hair matched like the top half of the
dress it was kind of layered and Shaggy
and then Nina Park did her makeup and
she just did that little subtle winged
liner which was perfect because the
dress obviously every I feel like every
look the dress speaks for itself you
know and you
let that statement show and she just
went for a winged liner and a little bit
of pink on those lips and she's got
those contours like on her own so I
don't think she needed to be doing
anything like that the cheek guys we're
winding down here and at the end we're
gonna kind of say who are each of our
favorite looks of the night were so we
want to know who yours are so leave them
on our Facebook page now moving into
Laverne Cox a moment in so many ways she
puts so much thought into her looks in
this gunmetal dress it was a custom
piece you know I talked to her and she
said she really has to get everything
custom-made for her because she's not a
sample size she has a different body
type and she had been wanting to wear
this color for a while and working on it
so it was a moment she was really
excited about let's hear her talk about
how she made the decision to wear
gunmetal named Khan he showed it in gold
and she had the idea of doing it in
gunmetal I wanted to do a gunmetal
moment for years and here we are the
jewels are Lorraine Schwartz and my
nails are from my new collection my
collaboration with Orly nails
called celebrate yourself I shadow it
was a very bold such a moment you know I
actually spoke with her makeup artist
Dasia Smith and she was saying that she
had requested of her Laverne had
requested glam with an edge so obviously
the dress was the inspiration but also
the 1939 film the woman was an
inspiration for her she imagined what
character from the movie she would look
like and she was over glammed a New York
fashionista socialite of today so she
kept it a little bit modern yeah nailed
it yes I thought it was interesting how
she said you know she saw it in gold I'm
so happy that she went with the gunmetal
color as opposed to the gold because
this looks like it was made just for her
yeah I think you have to be careful
wearing gold at awards shows because
people compare you to the statues yeah
like oh she looks like an ebony statue
out there you know you have to kind of
be careful with that especially when
you're doing something glittery but I
loved how it was all that beading and
had like a structure to it it was like
an architectural piece almost it was
super cool we got to talk about the men
a little bit yeah what they were wearing
and actually I
one woman were you guys statement
jackets were a really big thing on the
red carpet we talked to I talk to Lena
weaith from master of none who she wore
this I actually wear black and gold to
our recap today because black and gold
was also a big trend last night
she says she felt like an a pimp but a
nice one she's hilarious of course she
made history with her win last night but
she looked awesome and talked to Marcus
Scribner from blackish and he was
wearing a really similar jacket so my
guys was just working me statement
jackets you know as a guy you don't have
a lot to switch up you got to wear a
suit so they were really finding ways to
make it different last night which I
loved what do you guys think of jackets
like that
I feel like if you can find a funky and
fun tux jacket you could have to rock it
especially when it's somewhere like the
Emmys because at the Oscars you do have
to be a little more subtle and reserved
with your look Botox like yeah this is
the perfect place to do it I know Justin
Hartley to me he wore that navy ish
color and it was a little more subtle
but I also loved that on him is it was a
statement in its own right without all
the pattern yeah they got a pop yeah
they got a pop up the carpet exactly we
wanted to end on this hilarious moment
from unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt suspense
burger you talked to our own Nancy
O'Dell about how he picked his very bold
jacket go big or go home right
for our fashion segment then this tuxedo
makes me feel so Beyonce that might be
the best answer so far so true it just
came so naturally it was just like kind
of shy to it all right
favorite looks of the night you know
Mandy Moore I love that pink lip and
that beautiful Oreo dress I love Jessica
Biel were controversial appeal with the
hair I still loved it with the pompadour
I'm going to cold Kidman you guys my
lady in red what a night for her I
thought yeah she was my favorite
what about least favorite ooh you know I
will say I think you know Arielle winter
I think she's finding her way again but
I have to give her compliments on her
makeup because I thought the makeup was
just stunning thanks girl I love that
say the same for Arielle winter is
definitely probably top of the dress I
do have the top of the dress and I do
love Arielle and I like that she takes
fashion risks just maybe yeah yeah well
dress you guys we want to keep the
conversation going with you of course so
you can leave your comments on et's
Facebook page tweet at us we're all on
Twitter and Instagram and watch ET
tonight because there are gonna be so
many moments on the show that you did
not see on the Emmys broadcast we were
backstage we're on the red carpet we had
people at the parties so tons of stuff
there head to et online.com for all of
those interviews and the latest news
that we got on the red carpet
and we want to say thank you so much to
our friends at Fiji water for keeping us
hydrated as we power through the Emmys
yeah
all right everybody thanks so much and
have a great night think serene with
easy life bye guys
[Music]